-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
-We're back from hiatus.
This is "Late Night."
And, now, we're going to get
to the news.
President Biden traveled
to New Jersey and New York today
to survey storm damage from the
remnants of Hurricane Ida.
Then, he's going
to head to Texas
to look into that abortion law;
maybe drop by Florida,
to get some folks to wear masks,
if there's time;
head to California,
help with that recall mess;
and then,
finish up the week in Maine
to kill those lobster zombies.
Oh, did you not hear?
Yeah, every state
has something bad.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new poll,
President Biden's
approval rating
has dropped six points
since June.
But then, it went back up,
then, it fell again,
then, it went back up.
Then, it kind of fell again,
then it kind of just
stayed down for a while.
You know what?
I'm not being clear.
Do we have like
any sort of visual illustration?
[ Laughter ]
It's so helpful.
According to a new report,
former First Lady Melania Trump
has only been seen publicly
once this summer.
"Also privately,"
said her husband.
[ Laughter ]
We had to put his picture up
so people remember.
[ Laughter ]
A diner in Central Florida
last week
began receiving attention online
after it said it would not serve
anyone who voted
for President Biden.
I don't know how
to tell you this,
diner in Central Florida,
but you already weren't.
[ Laughter ]
What happened,
you got suspicious
after somebody tipped?
[ Laughter ]
Producers have announced
they'll delay the release
of the movie "Jackass" forever,
due --
Sorry, they're going to delay it
to next year.
Gosh, Wally, and I had you
put everything in quotes,
so I wouldn't stumble over it.
and this is my "Jackass,"
reading this card.
[ Laughter ]
Producers have announced
they'll delay the release
of the movie "Jackass Forever"
to next year,
due to a surge
in coronavirus cases.
Though, that would've made
a pretty good stunt.
"I'm Johnny Knoxville,
and this is
going to the movies
in a pandemic!"
Billionaire Mark Cuban
recently became an investor
in a start-up company
that is creating
artificial intelligence
versions of NFTs
that have the ability
to converse with people,
raising the obvious question --
"What?!"
[ Laughter ]
Amazon's medical business,
Amazon Cares,
reportedly looking to start
offering in-person visits
in 20 major U.S. cities,
and they're focusing
on the places where people need
the most medical help --
their own warehouses.